now for tonight's hashtagwars let's
begin in this time of unparalleled
political device of this America's
finally found a hero it can rally behind
I'm speaking of course about undecided
debate attendee and living Pringles
mascot Ken bone my new favorite person
in the universe even Twitter's moments
feature flat-out said quote Ken bone is
a national treasure hyperbole
I don't think so this guy is right up
there with Yellowstone National Park and
using donuts as hamburger buns I mean
check out Ken's Facebook page where it
turns out he also plays Pokemon go but
he plays as obi-wan Ken Boni
mmm I hope your team mr. Ken because the
red sweater I think you might be team
valor that's okay we can cross barriers
and still be friends
in fact he's taking on legendary status
like some kind of folk hero so an honor
of this sensible Paul Bunyan tonight's
hashtag is Ken bone facts ken bone facts
examples might be Ken bone is a
fraternal twin of every NFL assistant
coach and Ken bone doesn't give mustache
rides he gives mustache journeys and
here to help us out with this game all
the way from his home in Lizards thicket
the thrice divorced singer-songwriter
slim white man is here all right perfect
thank you very much I'm gonna put 60
seconds on the clock and begin
Kurt Ken bone owns over 1,000 DVDs but
they're all of the movie Sulley all
right soon Ken bones sleep apnea machine
gets cable
Kurt Ken bone sweater isn't read it just
blushes when he wears it listen when Ken
bone is stuck in traffic the N word he
yells is nutmeg